Luke here at the aggro boys YouTube
channel and me and my son Jake we're
taking my snow dog out into the
Wilderness of Alaska to go winter
camping in a hammock hot tent we're
going to be eating some amazing food
having a great time and trying not to
get eaten by wolves come along with a
ride it's gonna be a good time
[Music]
foreign
buddy you ready to go yeah
[Music]
don't worry I'll make another hole
so we're gonna make the hole bigger
as big as a large tent
do you like this hole
foreign
yeah it's
okay
foreign
what do you think Jake
is this a nice tent
all right Jake should we go get some
firewood
you got a perfect place
oh yeah that's a nice dead tree right
there
can you take this one back
all right
you like a little Snowshoe hair you can
float right on the snow
thank you
good good job
[Music]
all right
okay
questions
we got a nice
bison hide here help make it nice and
cozy
it's the homie touches that make a
difference
scoot up over here oh you got tons of
snow yeah oh yeah there you go
foreign
[Music]
how about hot dogs that sound good
all right let's do it oh look at this
that's how they used to
all right
daddy oh those for us those are for us
you want your button warm
all right you ready for a hot dog
all right
[Music]
hey is that a good hot dog
you know what daddy's gonna have on his
hot dog
sauerkraut here try a little sauerkraut
yeah
some kids just don't appreciate pickled
cabbage the mustard on here
all right two more hot dogs coming up
no okay okay
I think Jacob's feeling better now he's
got some food in them
a little bit cold Jake
you're very cold the stove isn't quite
uh heating this place up very well is it
let's get all warmed up now just make
sure you stay away from the stove I
don't want you to roll up against it
yeah it takes a little while to warm up
a sleeping bag
well we got Jacob snuggled up in his bag
so I'm gonna start cutting some firewood
we need to get this fire properly going
foreign
so all this wood is wet and frozen so we
just put it up on top of here to dry and
then whenever we need to soak the fire
we take from the dry pile
well the firewood's all cut and I've got
everything brought into the tent and the
sun's about to set I think it's time to
batten down the hatches and tuck it in
for the night
foreign
starting to set so I'm pulling out my
lights for filming I really like these
bicycle lights this is what I use for my
flood lighting when I'm filming at night
and when I'm winter camping I'm always
filming at night
it's bright but the fireplace turned
around so I can
work on it a bit
you hear that
foreign
it's getting time let's make some dinner
I gotta get all the Bison hairs out of
my pot all right for dinner tonight I'm
making a traditional Swiss camping food
fondue traditional fondue is pretty
simple you melt a bunch of shredded
cheese over a low heat you add a splash
of white wine and then you dip whatever
you want in it traditionally bread and
potatoes and meat and stuff like that
some cheeses work better than others
Fontina gouda gruyere are really good
fondue cheeses so I took a little bit of
each and mixed together now I'm not much
of a wine drinker so I just use white
vinegar or white wine vinegar and you
get the same results these little hot
tent stoves actually work really well
for making fondue because they're a nice
temperature
just want to add a little bit of cheese
at a time don't throw it all in at once
I've got some veggies and meat I want to
put in the fondue and I'm just gonna
stack these up on the stove let them
warm up
nice
[Music]
look at this Jacob
look at that
look at this the tee string
you want to try yourself yeah
what do you think buddy it's good
oh
oh you want some broccoli look at that
over here why don't you hold it like
this
it's nice and toasty you're you bring
your
oh that's so good
brussels sprouts got them seasoned with
a little sea salt and olive oil
[Music]
we got some meatballs you want a
meatball
Hey Jake do you want some chocolate milk
yeah
totally all right we gotta keep little
boys happy otherwise they won't go
camping with me
you try that out is that good
icy cold chocolatey milk
foreign
potatoes and cheese is an excellent
combination
wow I am so full of cheese and that was
delicious but I have got to stop eating
I am I am full
oh
all right Jake you want me to put you up
in the hammock
all right Jake where are you
oh there you are
on flashlight are you are you warm in
there yeah
yeah I got Jacob up in the hammock we
got dinner in our belly so we're just
hanging out and talking and
enjoying an evening well since you're
awake do you want to eat s'mores
it's gonna be a slow roast marshmallow
all right check that beauty out that is
a good marshmallow right there
I got a little bottle of Hershey
chocolate syrup here
dig you want that
I might have gigabyte
hmm
you like that
you all done oh all right Jake you going
to bed now
all right
got this nice bottle of boiling water to
keep my sleeping bag warm but I'm not
quite ready to go to bed so uh
just gonna put it right there
on that note I think I'm gonna get my
bed set up
always try to put something in between
the stove and my sleeping bag in case I
roll around in the night I don't want
that sleeping bag even touching that
stove it'll melt a hole or worse yet
catch on fire
go sleep and I'll see you guys in the
morning
well it's about 8 A.M so I'm gonna get
the fire going and start getting some
breakfast made before I get the stove
lit I've got to get some of this stuff
put away especially my sleeping bag if
my sleeping bag gets even close to the
stove it'll burn a hole that actually
happened on a camping trip about a year
and a half ago and it burned a hole
right in the foot of my bag took five
months to get it repaired
foreign
well this is my first time using this
hot 10 and I've got kind of mixed
feelings about it some of the big cons
is that it's not that warm it doesn't
really seal up properly at the end so
it's a bit drafty and this is really
spacious for being only a one maybe two
man tent so it's a large area to heat up
but that being said it's a very unique
hot tent and there really isn't anything
else like it on the market if you want a
hot tent where you can string a hammock
this is kind of it also you really
shouldn't think of it as a tent it's
just a tarp with a stove Jack on it I
bought this thing about a year ago so I
can't remember what I paid for it or
where I bought it but I'll go ahead and
put a link in the video description
below in case anybody wants to learn
more about it you think you're awake you
want to go back in the hammock okay well
you jumped out last night you promised
not to do that again
gotta use my inridge to send a message
to my wife let her know we didn't give
you my wolves
some frozen oil
bacon eggs and bagels
you take you want some bacon come up
here
it's like feeding my pet moray eel
let's go
all right guys now we got breakfast out
of the way I think it's time to clean up
and get the sled packed up
look at that
just completely melted that oh
foreign
up the wound here
from losing feathers on our way home I
think that'll be enough to just keep it
safe
foreign
it's time to get this little boy home
Hey Jake you okay in there
foreign
you ready to go home and kiss Mommy yes
[Music]
let's go home and see Mama
I'm Gonna Get You Too Much
[Music]
here let me take him inside I finished
kissing you too much
every time I do one of these campouts I
gotta dry out all my gear so I have all
these clamps around and I'll just clamp
and hang up all my tents and my mats and
my tarps and it even works with Buffalo
hides
foreign
all right you got that hung up and
drying
gotta pull out all my blades and let
them dry before I put them away
I gotta go through and charge up all my
headlamps my camera lights my GPS
tracker all that stuff I use this 10
Port USB block you gotta pull my saw
apart let it dry every time I do one of
these videos packing and unpacking
cleaning and repairing my gear takes up
almost an entire day it's like a whole
process and I do it every week
I keep all my sleeping bags in their
storage sack so they stay nice and puffy
I'm gonna try some of this Tenacious
Tape
all right it's not pretty but I'll keep
it from losing more feathers until
summer time then I can send it into the
company and have it fixed properly oh
there's so much bits of bacon and bread
crumbs in here
well listen I hope you guys enjoyed
watching this video as much as we
enjoyed filming it if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning we'll see you guys then
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching